à 8h15 sur europe1 l'heure de retrouver
sonia mabrouk question d'inviter ce
matin bruno retailleau président du
groupe et l'air au sénat ce sénateur de
vendée bienvenue et bon jour bruno
retailleau
bonjour à vous sonia mabrouk le premier
ministre va donc s'exprimer sur la
situation sanitaire tout à l'heure s'il
ya des décisions difficiles c'est qu'il
n'y a pas d'autre choix que la situation
l'imposent
j'avoue dire j'en ai marre qu'on rende
systématiquement responsables les
français de la moindre reprise
épidémique
la vérité c'est que les français font
preuve de civisme sans doute peut-il y
avoir parfois du relâchement
il faut le combattre mais la vérité
c'est que depuis des mois et des mois
depuis en réalité le premier confinement
le gouvernement n'a rien fait en tout
cas a fait beaucoup trop peu pour
contrôler cette épidémie cette épidémie
elle n'est pas contrôlée la seule façon
et ce sont les pays d'asie mais aussi
d'europe qui ont réussi à les contrôler
et qui nous montre l'exemple
il faut tracer je vous donne un chiffre
il est officiel sur trois semaines du
mois de novembre
on a en test de dépistage donc du pcr
fait deux fois moins
là encore sur le traçage c'est un fiasco
il faut faire comme japonais essayer de
trouver les super contaminateur qui sont
responsables de 80 à 90% des
contaminations et l'isolément
il y en a pas vous avez révélé ici sur
votre antenne que sur le territoire
français nous étions je crois à moins de
150 isolement c'est pas tous les
français qu'il faut confier qu'il faut
isoler ce sont les malades qu'il faut
isoler qu'il faut aussi soigner bien
bruno retailleau ya quelques mois ici
même vous vous prenez comme exemple
justement l'allemagne en au rapport le
pays voit ses indicateurs désormais
explosé c'est avec des larmes au bord
des yeux quand gala merkel appellent à
des restrictions la preuve qu'il n'ya
pas de solution miracle
les larmes d'angela merkel ne coule pas
sur les mêmes chiffres de mortalité par
million d'habitants l'allemagne ses 209
ou 210 morts par million d'habitants la
france c'est plus de 750 morts par
million d'habitants
vous vous rendez compte alors que nous
sommes frontaliers alors qu'on a souvent
parlé de l'amitié du couple franco
allemand il ya un pays qui réussit à
contrôler l'épidémie
casser la chaîne de contagion et un
autre qui n'y parvient pas malgré les
bons aujourd'hui autrement
malgré les frais l'antidote c'est la
confiance est ce que le gouvernement
peut inspirer la confiance aux français
pour qu'ils se mobilisent avec la sphère
des masses nous avons rêvé notre
commission denquête au sénat vient de
révéler infecté extrêmement grave lequel
qui est avérée encore une fois le fait
que monsieur saloum
le patron de la santé publique est
influer sur un rapport d'expertisé sur
le fameux stocks de masques c'est grave
tant d'essais ça grince il jérôme salle
vous avez des preuves certes est ancien
cette influence ses accesseurs dans
quelques heures la commission d' enquête
du sénat dévoilera l'ensemble de ses
conclusions elle sera j'en suis sûr
amen de révéler les échanges de mails
qu'elle a eu en sa possession et que va
tant que surveillant paris qui
prouverait quoi ces échanges est vrai
qu'il y a eu une interférence que
monsieur salomon a fait pression sur un
comité d'experts pour que celui-là
modifie ses conclusions en matière de
stocks de masques
donc si vous voulez pour moi on lutte
contre l'épidémie
avec une volonté politique avec une
vraie stratégie mais aussi en inspirant
confiance cette confiance a été rompue
des crises pas alors vous bruno
retailleau avec des objectifs qui ne
sont pas clairement atteint en france
quant à l'épidémie que prendriez vous
comme décision et que diriez-vous tout à
l'heure si vous étiez à la place du
premier ministre je prendrai comme
première décision sur notamment le
dépistage de faire en sorte d'utiliser
plus largement un test de dépistage pcr
salivaire en 40 minutes
vous avez et c'est ça il encore dit puis
je prendrai aussi la décision d'aller
chercher comme au japon les super
contaminateur je prendrai la décision
d'isoler de réquisitionner des hôtels de
faire en sorte qu' on puisse avoir non
pas un isolement qui soit obligatoire
mais qu'ils soient accompagnés qu'il
soit vous savez ce ne sera pas respectée
que ce n'est pas notre culture c'est
l'obligation proposition a suivi comme
les arrêts maladie par exemple pour ceux
qui travaillent
nous avons voté au sénat c'est une
mesure que j'ai soutenu le fait qu'il
n'y ait pas de jour de carence pour que
ceux qui acceptent l'isolément et bien
puisse rester chez eux sans perdre une
partie de leurs revenus c'est ça qui je
ferai et qu'il faut faire que je demande
au gouvernement de faire arrêter de
culpabiliser les français est aussi
faite
enfin ce que d'autres vérités je suis
quand même frappé ce matin d'entendre
vos accusations en tout cas ce que vous
dites par rapport à la commission
denquête au sénat ça veut dire que si
cela est avéré pour monsieur ça lui
manquait ce que vous demandez dans ce
cas là je demande que monsieur véran que
le gouvernement en tire les conséquences
c'est pas à moins que je suis là où
danny rand et simplement le sénat a fait
le travail comme l'assemblée nationale
la commission d' enquête révélera dans
quelques heures un certain nombre de ces
conclusions et mettra à la disposition
des observateurs intérêt aurait-il eu à
agir de la sorte quand même à l'enfiler
métropole rugby au delà de la force
qu'on a bien vu la grande faiblesse
qu'est-ce qui aura révélé vous savez
chaque crise est ajouts comme un
révélateur bien cette crise aura révélé
une sorte de toute puissance de la
bureaucratie française qui est dit dans
le rapport du sel se protège qui se
protège renault retail et c'était 1
principale conclusion de votre non non
non non mais c'est pas à moi de les
dévoiler tout c'est important quand même
si vous les dévoiler un système où la
vérité n'a pas été dite et il n'y a pas
eu de transparence là
des conséquences si tel est le cas je
prends cet exemple pour dire simplement
que j'en ai marre que le gouvernement
accuse systématiquement les français de
ses propres faiblesses est important on
verra aussi dans votre rapport ainsi
jérôme salomon a agi seul ça vous ne le
savez pas non plus c'est pas à moi de le
dire très bien le 25 novembre encore une
question sur la situation sanitaire
monsieur robayo vous avez déclaré sans
ambiguïté je me ferai vacciner
aujourd'hui avec de nouvelles données
sur de potentielles je dis bien de
potentiels effets secondaires et le
professeur et comme dit je n'ai jamais
vu autant d'effets secondaires êtes
toujours aussi volontariste et je serai
bien sûr je veux simplement dire vous
savez on est le pays de pasteur et qui
est le plus sceptique sur les 25
simplement je rappelle que avant
d'inventer le justement le vaccin contre
la variole variole tuer avec 300
millions personnes que la tuberculose
tous les ans tu es 3 millions personnes
donc je me ferai vacciner en temps ou en
heure ci il faut montrer l'exemple
je le ferai aussi je me ferai vacciner
c'est pas pour moi pas pour me protéger
avait dit c'est un acte de générosité
d'ousmane et oui c'est aussi un acte de
générosité
c'est pour protéger les autres pour
casser cette chaîne de contamination
parce que vous savez de confinement en
déconfinement enr confinement non
seulement il ya des morts mais il ya
aussi une économie une souffrance
sociale des pauvres qui se multiplient
en france et cette souffrance là elle
est terrible et et le vaccin sera aussi
un antidote
avec la confiance dont je parlais mais
la confiance il faut donc des garanties
aussi apporter aux français vous avez vu
les récentes enquêtes et sondages
diffusés mesurer l'audience de 10 c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me suis
toujours inscrit en faux j'étais contre
une vaccination obligatoire
en revanche là aussi on va attendre au
pied du mur le gouvernement parce qu'il
est une question de logistique
moi je suis favorable pour que le
gouvernement travaille beaucoup plus
avec les collectivités
je pense aussi qu'il doit travailler
avec le privé pour la logistique
saleh pour les masques on a vu que il
était incapable de fournir les masses
notamment aux personnels soignants le
privé sera mieux faire et laissons faire
les collectivités quand je vois que l'on
met des bâtons dans les roues de laurent
wauquiez
je le dis allez laurent n'hésite pas
vas-y ce que tu fais est très bien dans
l'actualité bruno retailleau le texte
confortant les principes républicains
est ce que ce texte tel qu'il a été
présenté hier par l'exécutif constitue
un tournant un bouclier contre
l'islamisme écoutez comme le disait tout
à l'heure l'un de vos éditorialistes est
un grand bouillon d'eau tiède pensez
vous une seule seconde que ce texte
aurait pu empêcher l'un des trois
derniers attentats non puisqu'ils ont
été commis par des immigrés est que ce
texte laisse de côté le désordre
migratoire je veux rappeler que nice
c'est un tunisien
je veux rappeler aussi que les locaux
charlie hebdo c'est là encore un faux
mineures je crois pakistanais je veux
rappeler aussi sam elle pâtit c'est un
tchétchène d'ailleurs c'était incroyable
on a vu d'ailleurs son inhumation dans
son pays c'était quasiment un héros
national ça devrait nous inquiéter et
bien non le texte ne fera rien de plus
le problème c'est qu'ils pratiquent
l'amalgamé ce texte rien valgames c'est
l'exécutif qui pratiquent l'amalgamé
alors qu'il ce qu'il essaye de ne pas
donner le sentiment d'un texte anti
islam justement est contre cette
religion mais justement parce qu'il ne
veut pas nommer l'islamisme il amalgame
parce qu'il laisse à penser que par
parler de l'iss a mis ça pourrait mettre
en difficulté les musulmans non riace
ces deux choses très différentes mais
surtout comme il ne cible pas ces
mesures
tout le monde va en prendre pour son
grade toutes les religions y a pas de
problème avec le gif ya pas de problème
inquiète protestants et les catholiques
etc
eh bien on arrose tout le monde en
sulfates tout le monde regardez la
scolarisation obligatoire
on va passer d'un régime de liberté un
régime de restriction des déceptions
reconnaissons le non mais c'est ça sera
un régime d'exception y fera que telle
ou telle montre qu' il rentre dans la
case contrôlée par l'état alors que il
faut contrôler bien ces labels de la
transparence monsieur retailleau pour
avoir toutes les données pour avoir tous
les garde-fous et lutter contre sa peine
une mesure liberticide
il y en a marre aussi on voit bien on
voit bien que regarder l'article 24
regardé l'avant il y avait la loi avia
on a finalement pris des mesures qui
sont des mesures alors heureusement
l'arctique en kata pas été votée
liberticide pour la liberté
d'information pour la liberté scolaire
c'est une mesure liberticide
cet article notamment qui restreint
cette liberté qui lie puisque vous nous
dit le texte
la jauge de 30 vous citez les attentats
mais très sincèrement monsieur
retailleau quel texte quel projet de loi
qu'est ce qui aurait pu empêcher les
attentats il n'y a pas de risque zéro
ou vous avez raison de dire qu'il n'y a
pas de risque zéro je dis moi je réponds
que la lutte contre l'islamisme et le
terrorisme islamiste c'est une affaire
de longue haleine évidemment que c'est
aussi une affaire qui concerne les
français et c'est un combat global ce
que je veux dire c'est que on peut pas
penser combattre l'islamisme seulement
en combattant le terrorisme ya un
terreau de l'islamisme le terreau de
l'islamisme
ce sont les enclaves les territoires
conquis comme le disait le chercheur
benarrous j ai marre cet islamisme sur
la république c'est aussi l'aspect
symbolique dans les mémoires moi je me
bats pour qu'on arrête cette vision
lacrymal pénitentielle de l'histoire de
france
parce que plus on dira que la france
comme l'avait dit le président de
république
elle est coupable du crime de l'humanité
et bien non plus on dira que la france
est coupable de tout et plus on
n'empêchera ces jeunes qui sont sur le
chemin de la sécession d'entrer dans
notre budget collectif mais nationale
mais l'exécutif qui fait bien attention
à ne pas donner le sentiment d'un texte
anti islam à ce que vous dites malgré
tous un discours équilibré qu'il faut
tenir vu les divisions détention d'un
autre pays moi je ne confonds pas
évidemment mais ce ce texte ne fera rien
plus regardée par exemple sur les signes
ostentatoires sur le voile le premier
des séparatismes c'est le marquage des
petites filles ou des femmes avec le
voile c'est essayer de distinguer dans
la population française c'est aussi et
de faire porter aux femmes ce signe qui
leur signifiaient aux jo monsieur
retailleau là la roja contre l'idéologie
doko y sont on agit sur les associations
sur les services publics le voile cette
j'allais dire les frères aux salafistes
utilise le voile comme un symbole comme
un marqueur de l'idéologie
qui est le marqueur du séparatisme j'ai
fait voter nous avons voté au sénat
l'interdiction par exemple les signes
ostentatoires religieux pour les sorties
scolaires dans le temps scolaire c'est
interdit à l'école les sorties scolaires
c'est l'école hors les murs on interdit
aussi le gouvernement l'a refusée idem
sur les listes les candidats
communautariste il faut savoir si on a
une vraie volonté aussi on a pas de
volonté mais sur texte encore une fois
de réglera aucun problème volet
malheureusement aux libertés elle
volonté pour conclure chez les
républicains juste en un mot et vous
proposer un système de vote préférentiel
1 c'est la primaire qui pousserait à
hiérarchiser plutôt qu'à éliminer
j'ai essayé de comprendre ce matin bruno
testa vous fait sourire il faut avoir
fait l'ena pour comprendre notre système
non monsieur j'ai pas fais là ce que je
veux simplement dire très rapidement je
n'entrerai pas dans le calcul
mathématique ce que je veux simplement
dire c'est que au moment où on se bat
pour avoir une meilleure participation
mon ma famille politique ne voudrais pas
que nos électeurs nos militants
participent au choix du candidat
je pense que c'est important et je pense
que la primaire c'est d'abord non pas la
primaire entre des candidats à la
primaire entre les idées entre des
projets je pense que pour nourrir un
débat
y'a pas mieux j'ai tiré les leçons et
d'aller vers des positions proposition
n'est retiré ses leçons et je pense que
il faut maintenant en discuter c'est ce
que je souhaite parce que je ne veux pas
qu'ils aient un bis repetita et qu'on se
retrouve dans le même cas de figure au
2e tour madame le menu de ce lyon bruno
retailleau d'abord était notre invité ce
matin merci à vous